Deutschland in der gasklemme jetzt kauft
die Regierung im Rekordtempo Flüssiggas
aus aller Welt und lässt sich dafür
feiern das würde ich sagen ein Tag der
Entschlossenheit quasi einen Tag des
ausrufeszeichens wenn man so will
doch die Kritik am vollgaskurs ist laut
es ist bitter dass wir jetzt wieder ein
Anfang neue fossile Infrastrukturen zu
bauen
Riesenprojekte langfristige
Lieferverträge alles für einen
Brennstoff der nur eine Übergangslösung
sein soll
das Fracking Gas das ist das dreckigste
das umweltschädlichste Gas das es gibt
auf der Welt
der lng-hunger treibt weltweit die
Preise nach oben und geht auf Kosten
armer Länder
der nimmt ein mächtiger Mann alles mit
was er bekommen kann zu Lasten alle
anderen Menschen
wir fragen ist die deutsche lng-politik
ein Ausweg oder ein Irrweg
[Musik]
die Politik gibt Vollgas und zwar
tiefgekühlt in Form von LNG
verflüssigtem Erdgas das wird in großen
Tankschiffen übers Meer angeliefert
gigantische Terminal Schiffe wandeln den
flüssigen Brennstoff dann wieder in Gas
um deren Ankunft in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel und Lubmin wird bejubelt als
die Rettung aus unseren Energieproblemen
wann immer ein von der Regierung
gepachtetes Terminal eröffnet wird kommt
das Who is Who der Politik und feiert
die eigene Entschlossenheit mit einem
ganz neuen deutschland-tempo ist hier
schnell alles fertig geworden
in der Tat außergewöhnlich innerhalb
weniger Monate werden auch die
pipeline-anschlüsse von der Küste ans
Deutsche Erdgasnetz gebaut doch brauchen
wir eigentlich so viel LNG Karin Arnold
forscht seit Jahren zu Entwicklung der
Energieversorgung
wir müssen akzeptieren dass wir
kurzfristig fossile Energie benötigen
aber wir müssen nicht akzeptieren dass
wir einfach darin verharren und die noch
jahrelang weiter nutzen obwohl wir
eigentlich es besser wissen
doch die Regierung verfolgt erneut und
Ostsee ganz große Pläne zahlreiche
Terminals sind bereits beschlossen
weitere in Planung ab 2025 sollen drei
feste Terminals drei der schwimmenden
Terminal Schiffe ersetzen dann kann
Deutschland mehr Gas importieren als je
zuvor
wenn wir die wirklich bauen würden dann
würden wir am Ende mehr LNG verbrennen
als wir das zu den Zeiten der russischen
Erdgaslieferung hatten das ist eine
politische Fehlsteuerung dass wir am
Bedarf vorbei diese terminalplan
ist diese terminalplanung sinnvoll der
erfahrene Wirtschaftsjournalist malte
kreuzfeld kennt geheime
regierungspapiere daraus geht hervor
dass Ministerium hat nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt wie viel Gas aus den
Nachbarländern kommen kann sehr bekommen
wir sehr viel mehr Gas als in der
Vergangenheit über die LNG terminals in
unsere Nachbarländern die waren in der
Vergangenheit Nutzen im Drittel etwa
ausgelastet haben also sehr viel
Kapazitäten noch und das scheint das
Wirtschaftsministerium in seinen
Berechnungen auch gar nicht so richtig
berücksichtigt zu haben
kann das sein dass im Ministerium am
Bedarf vorbeigeplant wird am Rande einer
Terminal Eröffnung können wir den
Wirtschaftsminister dazu befragen
wie sehen Sie die Vorwürfe dass sie viel
zu viele Terminals geplant haben ja die
sind nicht richtig und sie kommen aus
einer
Vergesslichkeit heraus wir haben eine
noch immer eine mega angespannte Lage ja
wir haben die Hälfte des Gas der
gasinfrastruktur der Gaslieferung
verloren und was wir jetzt machen mit
diesen Schiffen ist in diesem Jahr ein
Drittel des verlorenen Gases in der
Kapazität und im nächsten Jahr das
nächste Drittel also zwei Drittel
reparieren wird zu machen oder die
Überkapazität ist sondern immer eine
erklären
die Erklärung stammt aus seinem
Ministerium das plant so und das
Deutschland ab 2026 sogar mehr Gas
importieren kann als früher aus Russland
denn zu den zusätzlichen Importen aus
europäischen Ländern kommen die
schwimmenden Terminals hinzu und dann
die fest installierten die Gasimporte
können sogar höher werden als vor dem
Ukraine Krieg der Verbrauch muss aber
sinken sonst werden die Klimaziele nicht
erreicht
erneuerbare Energien sollen LG ersetzen
überzählige Terminal Schiffe Bilder
Minister dann weitervermieten
dann fahren die Schiffe wieder weg das
tolle an diesen Schiffen ist ja dass sie
schwimmen können also eine flexible
Nutzung möglich ist
geht das wirklich so flexibel mit den
lng-terminals wir fragen bei der
Deutschen Umwelthilfe nach wie sie das
sieht
[Musik]
es ist eine offene Frage ob die Terminal
Schiffe tatsächlich in 5 10 oder 12
Jahren verchartert werden können das
glaube wir müssen da unsere Denkweise
ändern wir dürfen jetzt einfach keine
neuen Investitionen in diese fossilen
Energieträger und ihre Infrastruktur
tätigen sondern wir müssen Investitionen
tätigen die uns ermöglichen daraus
auszusteigen
Deutschland kauft jetzt LNG mit
langlaufenden Verträgen das führt dazu
dass mehr Länder auf Gasförderung setzen
und das schadet dem Klima
das ist so dass jetzt durch diesen
deutschen Energiehunger ein Anreiz
entsteht eine neue Gasförderung
anzufangen beispielsweise in Afrika ein
Senegal und das ist eine fatale
Entwicklung weil wir wissen aus der
Klimawissenschaft dass wir jetzt keine
neuen Kohlenstoffquellen mehr anzapfen
dürfen und damit kommen wir in einen
ganz fatalen Kreislauf der am Ende es
uns global schwerer machen wird die
Klimaziele zu erreichen
für 15 Jahre hat sich Deutschland
vertraglich an flüssiges erdgasgebunden
plant mit enormen Mengen und das obwohl
die ampelregierung die Energiewende
schnell schaffen will
die Esperanza ist das erste
einsatzfähige schwimmende Terminal in
Deutschland und wir sind das erste
Fernsehteam dass sich anschauen kann wie
das funktioniert wenn flüssiges Erdgas
geliefert wird
die Esperanza kann große Mengen davon
aufnehmen die rund - 160 Grad kalte
Flüssigkeit wird erwärmt und
anschließend gasförmig in die Pipeline
eingespeist
Holger Krebs ist zuständig für den
reibungslosen Betrieb der regaifizierung
der Anleger und der Anschluss an das
deutsche Pipeline-Netz wurden in
Rekordgeschwindigkeit fertig
zeigen wir haben ja da draußen im
Prinzip an dem Jetty die ganze
Infrastruktur neu bauen müssen damit das
Schiff hier auch anders fahren kann
Anfang 2023 sind in Deutschland drei
Terminals in Betrieb dank des LNG
beschleunigungsgesetzes werden fast 100
km Pipeline zu den Terminal Schiffen mit
Ausnahmegenehmigungen gebaut
wegen Explosionsgefahr bestehen an Bord
höchste Sicherheitsanforderungen
das ist jetzt im Prinzip eine Kamera die
sicherungsgeschützt ist vor vor
Funkenschlag und sowas deshalb dürfen
wir mit anderen Kameras draußen nicht
Filmen ja dann gehen wir mal raus er
leiht uns sein sicherheitszertifiziertes
Handy nur damit dürfen wir in der Nähe
der Gasleitungen Filmen mittlerweile ist
hier richtig Winterwetter und immer eine
Erinnerung ehrlicherweise daran warum
war das hier machen nämlich für die
kalten Wintertage neues Gas nach
Deutschland zu holen der Grund warum wir
jetzt hier sind ist natürlich
ehrlicherweise ein ziemlich beschissener
Grund nämlich ein Krieg in Europa und
sozusagen deshalb so richtig freuen kann
man sich jetzt da irgendwie nicht
auf der Meeresseite liegt der LNG-Tanker
hier sieht man eigentlich ganz schön
leit
ungen das Flüssigkeit von dem lng-schiff
auf die Esperanza transportiert werden
alles funktioniert
Technik läuft einwandfrei und ab jetzt
kommt hier jede Woche so ein Schiff an
das eisigkalte verflüssigte Erdgas das
hier per Tankschiff ankommt hat aber
eine Nachteil gegenüber Erdgas aus der
Pipeline es ist eben flüssigt
Verflüssigung ist immer ein Vorgang der
sehr viel Energie kostet und mit dieser
Energie verbunden sind natürlich auch
Emissionen das heißt der
emissionsrucksack erhöht sich im
Gegensatz zum gasförmigen Erdgas ganz
erheblich
auch beim Thema Umweltschutz gibt es ein
großes Problem das terminalschiff in
Wilhelmshaven nutzt umstrittene Technik
mehr Wasser wird zum Aufwärmen des LNG
genutzt die meerwasserleitungen werden
mit giftigem Chlor einem sogenannten
Biozid sauber gehalten
[Musik]
Biozid wird eingesetzt um ein Bewuchs
mit Muscheln und Seepocken in den
Anlagen zu verhindern Muscheln und
Seepocken und andere Meereslebewesen
sind aber ja genau das was wir im
Nationalpark Watten mehr der da gleich
nebenan ist schützen möchte
der Betreiber Juniper verweist darauf
dass die Chlorierung genehmigt ist beim
Termin in Brunsbüttel fehlt die Zeit den
Minister dazu zu fragen
sein Sprecher räumt ein dass die
Chlorierung problematisch ist
das ist im Grunde nicht mehr Stand der
Technik der neueste Stand der Technik
ermöglicht ohne Chlorierung zu arbeiten
für uns ist klar das ist wichtig ist
dass jetzt geguckt wird ob es auch eine
alternative das gehört jetzt dazu zu der
Praxis die da vor Ort ist
LNG soll den Güterverkehr sauberer
machen doch der Preis stieg dramatisch
auch wegen des deutschen gashungers das
trifft Spediteur Wolfgang Normann der
große Mengen für seine umgerüstete
LKW-Flotte braucht
Norman setzte auf LNG als Alternative zu
Diesel er hat den Familienbetrieb 2019
auf den umweltfreundlicheren Treibstoff
umgestellt mitsamt eigener Tankstelle
wir haben ein sehr großes Investment
gemacht aber dennoch waren alle sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir damals den
richtigen Schritt
gegangen sind
heute tanken 40 seiner 60 Laster LNG
der Aufwand ist nicht viel größer als
beim Betanken mit Diesel
er hat die Laster neu gekauft 5
Millionen in die gasumstellung gesteckt
doch der Spediteur bereut seine
Entscheidung und der Gaspreis ist Monat
für Monat für Monat immer weiter
gestiegen und nach wie vor wir wissen
nicht wo das Ende sein wird
der lng-preis ist im Vergleich zu Diesel
bis zu seinem Höchststand im Sommer 2022
drastisch gestiegen
die hohen Kosten können die Spediteure
kaum an ihre Kunden weitergeben denn die
akzeptieren selten die dadurch
steigenden Frachtgebühren
in Summe haben wir Mehrkosten von über
400.000 Euro im Monat was uns alleine
das Gas kostet Verluste von 400.000
schaffen wir keine vier Wochen zu tragen
inzwischen hat sich der Gaspreis etwas
beruhigt doch noch immer kämpft Norman
täglich darum die Firma am Laufen zu
halten im Sommer 2022 musste er sogar
viele teure lng-laster stilllegen sein
Engagement für Klimaschutz hat ihn
beinahe ruiniert
die Spedition kämpft ums Überleben
zahlreiche mittelständische
energieintensive Firmen sind schon
pleite
Henning leuschstein analysiert den
deutschen und internationalen Öl-
wir machen uns weniger Sorgen um die
große Industrie die kann umziehen die
kann investieren die kann sich verlagern
als um mittelständische Unternehmen die
sitzen auf der gleichen Rechnung wie
Haushalte und gucken sich die Preise an
und denken sich
das betrifft auch Oku chemicals der
Mittelständler kann nicht wie
Weltkonzerne seine Produktion ins
Ausland verlagern in Deutschland
beschäftigt das Unternehmen knapp 1000
Mitarbeiter die Firma arbeitet mit
Synthesegas das aus Erdgas hergestellt
wird und Grundstoff für zahlreiche
chemische Erzeugnisse ist
das sind wirkliche basische Chemikalien
die und die sind Teil unserer täglichen
Lebens
sie werden an andere Unternehmen
verkauft die Stellen daraus Kosmetika
Schaumstoffe Öle und unzählige weitere
Produkte her doch trotz der vielen
Verwendungsmöglichkeiten findet die
Firma seit Beginn der ukraine-krise
immer weniger Abnehmer
und Gaspreise kann Oliver Borgmeier kaum
weitergeben
es gibt eine ganze Menge Produkte die im
Moment einfach nicht verkaufbar sind zum
einen weil in Europa kein Bedarf ist und
weil unsere Kosten hier so hoch sind
sind wir nicht in der Lage dass
außerhalb von Europa zu verkaufen weil
Produzenten in Nordamerika Produzenten
in Asien Produzenten in Mittel liest
einfach viel viel wettbewerbsäge
herstellen können zu deutlich
niedrigeren Kosten
Opio chemicals ging es gut kurz vor dem
Ukraine Krieg hat der Chemie Multi einen
hohen Millionenbetrag in die
Modernisierung investiert doch mit der
Explosion der Preise auch für Gas als
Rohstoff wackelt das Geschäftsmodell
haben sie nun ungefähren Richtwert was
sie im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr ein
Gas jetzt mehr zahlen am Hausnummer das
waren so um die 150 Millionen
150 Millionen
Mehrkosten Mehrkosten das ist
signifikant ja
nicht nur in seinem Werk sind die
Umsätze eingebrochen für viele
Unternehmen der chemischen Industrie ist
der Standort Deutschland derzeit nicht
mehr attraktiv
was man sich natürlich schon fragt macht
man noch Investitionen um das Werk hier
wachsen zu lassen oder um hier neue
Anlagen hinzubauen und das würde ich
sagen ist in der aktuellen Situation
wirklich zweifelhaft
währenddessen bezieht seine Konkurrenz
etwa in den USA billiges Gas und kann
weitaus günstiger produzieren
und jetzt hier nicht hergestellt wird
dann wird so anders hergestellt aber
dann sind die Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland und in Europa sind dann weg
Borgmeier ist sauer auf die
ampelregierung die hat eine
gaspreisbremse beschlossen sie greift
aber nur wenn Gas aus der Pipeline kommt
und zur Energieerzeugung genutzt wird
wer Gas als Rohstoff nutzt wie ok
chemicals geht leer aus
was wäre ihre Forderung ganz konkret an
die Politik das gaspreisbremsengesetz
Nachschärfen und das zugänglich machen
für stoffliche Verwertung an
chemiestandorten wie wir das sind
der Bundesminister verteidigt sein
Gesetz
die stoffliche Nutzung ist von der
gaspressbremse nicht erfasst sondern es
geht um die Verwendung im Energiesektor
also im Energiesektor und das kann man
auch nicht denn das sind dann ja
wirtschaftliche Prozesse die dann
entweder über andere Importe laufen
müssen oder sich über neue
Geschäftsmodelle neue orientieren müssen
neue Geschäftsmodelle oder eben
Insolvenz denn wer wie Spediteur
Wolfgang Normann Gas in flüssiger Form
also als LNG nutzt fällt auch nicht
unter die gaspreisbremse wir
wissen nicht was alles auf uns kommt
dass das ist schwer einzuschätzen was
bedeutet das für Sie persönlich wenn sie
zusperren müssen
im Worst Case würde das auch vermischt
die private Insolvenz bedeuten denn
diese Film viele Millionen die auf
Einschlag fällig sind haben wir
natürlich nicht auf dem Konto liegen
das Vermögen der Familie steckt in der
Firma floss in den lng-ausbau Wolfgang
Normann kämpft weiter denn sonst
verlieren 150 Menschen ihre Arbeit und
auch die Familie ist von der Insolvenz
betroffen
die LKWs würden in die Versteigerung
kommen da diese aber Wirtschaftlichkeit
nicht einsetzbar sind haben diese
aktuell keinen Marktwert würden
möglicherweise zum Schrottwert
verscherbelt werden
er wollte etwas für klimafreundlichere
Logistik tun doch jetzt wird LNG nur
subventioniert wenn es wieder gasförmig
durch eine Pipeline kommt ohne
gaspreisbremse hat es sich damit für
viele Spediteure erledigt
unsere Forderung wäre dass die Politik
den Unternehmen die den Willen der
Politik umgesetzt haben nicht im Stich
lässt
das fordert auch die linke Opposition in
Berlin
ich glaube dass Gaspreis bremsengesetz
ist auch mit heißer Nadel gestrickt
worden und es gibt ganz viele Bereiche
des Lebens die eben ausgeblendet wurden
so wie die gaspreisbremse gestaltet ist
lässt sie weite Teile der Wirtschaft im
Regen stehen egal wie viele LNG
importiert wird
ein Großteil des lngs auf dem Markt
stammt aus den USA dort wird das Gas
überwiegend durch Fracking gewonnen mit
erheblichen Umweltproblemen
beim Fracking wird ein Wasser Sand
Chemikalien Gemisch unter hohem Druck in
den Boden gepresst und bricht dort
gashaltige Gesteinsschichten auf an der
Oberfläche wird es bei minus 162 Grad
verflüssigt und dann per LNG Tankschiff
in die ganze Welt geliefert
das ist ein Riesenproblem weil es immer
wieder vorkommt dass diese Chemikalien
dann auch ins Trinkwasser ins
Grundwasser gelangen das Erdbeben
ausgelöst werden und es ist ein sehr
flächenintensiver Prozess und das macht
es eben insgesamt zu einer besonders
schmutzigen und dreckigen Methode um das
zu fördern
deshalb ist Tracking in Deutschland seit
Jahren verboten
es stimmt dass wir natürlich die
Verantwortung die Schäden die
Schwierigkeiten sozusagen gerne da
lassen wo sie eben in den Lieferländern
liegt das ist natürlich nicht richtig
sondern wir müssen dafür auch irgendwo
natürlich Verantwortung nehmen und
gerade stehen
von diesem Problem redet bei den großen
Feierlichkeiten zur
lng-terminal-eröffnung keiner
es ist bitter dass wir jetzt wieder ein
Anfang neue fossile Infrastrukturen zu
bauen wo wir eigentlich dabei sein
müssten neue Windräder neue
Photovoltaikzellen und Grüne
Wasserstoffe Infrastrukturen aufzubauen
und deswegen kann das nur eine
Momentaufnahme sein aber niemals für die
langen Zeiträume wo es jetzt geplant ist
die Politik kündigt an lng-infrastruktur
soll zukünftig für sauberen Wasserstoff
genutzt werden
die Terminals die hier dann fest
errichtet werden sind Wasserstoff
Terminals also die Perspektive von
Wilhelmshaven mit den
landgebundenen Terminals geht klar auf
Wasserstoff
doch die Wasserstoff Zukunft ist unklar
flüssig ist der
-250° kalt dafür müssen spezielle
Anlagen gebaut werden Tankschiffe dafür
gibt es kaum als Gas ist der
hochexplosiv ein Sicherheitsrisiko der
Import von Wasserstoff ist heute erstmal
eine gute Geschichte und eine
Beruhigungspille für die Öffentlichkeit
macht euch keine Sorge das wird später
alles irgendwie grün werden Wasserstoff
zu verschenken ist derzeit ungeheuer
teuer und ein an sich noch in den
nächsten 10 Jahren völlig unrealistisch
zur Erinnerung die Regierung hat LG
Lieferverträge von bis zu 15 Jahren
geschlossen 9 Terminals sind geplant
teils fest
im Bundeshaushalt sind dafür bislang 10
Milliarden Euro vorgesehen die Politik
des Bundes ist extrem teuer man hat auch
nicht den Eindruck dass darüber
nachgedacht wurde wie denn das Geld
aufgebracht werden soll und über 15
Jahre solche Pläne zu machen ist einfach
verantwortungslos haushaltspolitisch
aber auch für die Umwelt
wird nun also für viel Geld viel zu viel
Gas importiert die drohenden
Überkapazitäten will der Minister
weiterverkaufen
nach dem Wegfall und dem vermutlicher
länger bleibenden Wegfall der russischen
Gaslieferung für Osteuropa ist der Weg
Osteuropa zu versorgen durch Deutschland
durch wer ich will mir nicht den Vorwurf
anziehen zu sagen hättest du mal ein
bisschen mehr Reservekapazität
geschaffen dann hätten wir jetzt nicht
viele die nächste not man kann natürlich
auch sagen Feuerwehr ist zu teuer sparen
wir nicht also wir halten sowas nicht
vor aber das wäre wirklich geschichts
vergessen nach den letzten Jahren
doch momentan gibt es in Europa schon
dutzende Terminals und es werden noch
viel mehr gebaut es fehlt an politischer
Abstimmung
über das gaspipeline-netz können die
europäischen Länder und auch Deutschland
in hohem Maße versorgt werden so viele
Deutsche Terminals und lng-importe wie
geplant sind also nicht nötig und das
Geld das jetzt in LNG gesteckt wird
fehlt für Investitionen in die
Energiewende für Windräder und Grünen
Wasserstoff
es ist teuer das ist gar keine Frage wir
müssen erstmal investieren Frage ist was
ist die Alternative nicht investieren
und sagen ja die Verbraucher müssen
weiter die hohen Preise zahlen das wäre
der die Konsequenz Gas bleibt knapp wir
haben eine Notlage ihr müsst alle weiter
sparen und die Preise die schießen uns
durch die Decke
die Zahl der deutschen Terminals
reduziert aber nicht den Gaspreis der
wird anders gebildet
der Gaspreis hängt jetzt nicht von der
Menge der Terminals ab sondern der hängt
ja von der Menge des zur Verfügung
stehenden LNG ab bei insgesamt wird das
LMG nicht billiger dadurch dass es mehr
Terminals gibt im Prinzip wird bildet
sich der lng-preis in den Weltmärkten
und nicht an den deutschen Terminals der
Preis an den Weltmärkten ist 2022 durch
die europäische Nachfrage explodiert mit
gravierenden Folgen
es ist genug da für die die sich das
leisten können wenn man also richtig
viel Gas haben will und richtig viel
bezahlen kann dann bekommt man auch Gas
die brutal Realität ist dass in ärmeren
länderns dazu mangeladen bekommen die
können sich das schlicht und einfach
nicht leisten
das Schwellenland Pakistan es ist auf
LNG importer angewiesen es hat keine
Pipelines in die Nachbarländer und
wollte seine Kohlevorräte nicht
ausbeuten
doch seit Deutschland und Europa den
Gasmarkt leer kaufen kommt immer weniger
LG in Pakistan an die LG Group ist einer
der beiden großen LG Importeure im Land
deren Chef
ignal Ahmed hat den Titel King of gas
er ist in der Energiebranche reich
geworden
ich glaube der Westen wurde gierig da
nimmt ein mächtiger Mann alles mit was
er bekommen kann zu Lasten alle anderen
Menschen das hat der Welt keinen guten
Dienst erwiesen in Tunes in der heutigen
Welt muss man allen eine Chance zum
Überleben lassen ich befürchte dass der
Westen dass diesen anderen Ländern
verwehrt
weil das Gas für die Verstromung fehlt
wird im Land der Strom rationiert und es
kommt zu Blackouts im Haushalt unseres
Kameramanns ist gerade wieder
Stromausfall doch er kann sich eine
Batterie leisten
das Gas für den Herd kommt und geht
die Belieferung ist unregelmäßig das hat
nicht nur Folgen für das Alltagsleben
der Menschen sondern auch für die
gesamte Wirtschaft
er Flat wegen im Laufe des Tages kein
Gas zur Verfügung steht läuft die
Industrie nicht wenn die Industrie nicht
läuft leiden unsere Exporte wenn unsere
Exporte leiten wird unser
Leistungsbilanz Defizit größer das führt
zu Arbeitslosigkeit und großen
finanziellen Problemen
im Hafen Kasim in Karachi liegen die
zwei lng-terminal Schiffe Pakistans seit
der Westen das LNG zu jedem Preis kauft
kommen hier rund 20% weniger flüssig-
Tanker mit LNG für Pakistan werden
einfach Richtung Europa umgelenkt
geltende langfristige Verträge werden
nicht erfüllt sondern lieber die
Vertragsstrafe gezahlt
mehrere Lieferanten die Verträge hatten
haben ihre Sicherheitszahlung verfallen
lassen und einfach nicht geliefert denn
damit verdienen sie zehnmal mehr als das
was sie als Strafe zahlen müssen
Pakistan kann sich kein Gas vom
sogenannten Spotmarkt leisten das ist
der Markt für LNG das quasi am nächsten
Tag geliefert wurde
doch durch die hohe Nachfrage Europas
sind die Preise viel zu hoch gestiegen
die Folgen spüren die große Industrie
etwa näher rein und die kleinen
Unternehmen die in dem armen Land Arbeit
und auskommen für viele schaffen
wie etwa der pfeifferkäufer Verrat in
seinem kleinen Café im Zentrum
zur Zeit sind die Lebensumstände hier in
Karachi sehr schwer für uns wir sind
sehr besorgt wegen der steigenden Kosten
für Gas ich hoffe dass sich die
Situation irgendwann normalisieren wird
obwohl er einen Gasanschluss hat wird er
nicht beliefert das knappe Gut geht nur
noch an wohlhabender
wir kriegen hier kein Gas mehr deshalb
müssen wir uns Gasflaschen kaufen unsere
Kosten haben sich deshalb verdoppelt
weil wir jetzt auf teure Gasflaschen
angewiesen sind und zusätzlich noch
Steuern für den Gaszähler bezahlen
müssen obwohl gar nichts mehr ankommt
alle die nur Mindestlohn bekommen leiden
sehr darunter
vielen geht das wie ihm sie können die
teure Gaslieferung nicht mehr bezahlen
wenn sie etwas gespart haben kaufen sie
sich überteuertes Gas in Flaschen für
das ganze Land sehe eine Lösung anders
aus schmutzige Braunkohle abbauen
wegen wer heute gierig ist sorgt dafür
dass Länder wie Pakistan auf schmutzige
Kohle umsteigen die Länder werden nach
allen schmutzigen Tricks greifen um zu
überleben das wird langfristig die
Nachfrage nach LNG und auch die
Wirtschaft des Westens schädigen
das gleiche Problem haben Indien
Bangladesch und Länder in Afrika sie
können sich LNG kaum mehr leisten und
setzen wieder auf schmutzige
Energiequellen wie Kohle oder Erdöl
der neue Energiehunger führt somit zu
gravierenden Umwelt und Klimaschäden im
Rest der Welt die Folgen werden sich
noch Jahrzehnte auswirken
wie sehen Sie das wenn man ihnen
vorwirft zu viel zu kaufen und die armen
Länder dabei zu vergessen
ist es richtig dass der Weltmarkt so
funktioniert dass diejenigen die
bezahlen können das Gas bekommen für den
letzten Sommer war es so dass Europa und
auch Deutschland in Europa seine Not
auch zu lassen von anderen Ländern
gelindert hat das ist eindeutig der Fall
das kann man gar nicht weg diskutieren
immer energieverhalten in entwickelten
Ländern ist noch nie fair gewesen
insofern setzen wir diese sehr ungute
Tradition fortan der Stelle natürlich
ist das nicht fair
die Regierung steckte in einem Dilemma
als das russische Gaswerk fiel doch ihre
lng-pläne fordern einen hohen Preis für
die Umwelt die Klimaziele den Haushalt
und global
wo es noch geht sollten die Planungen
besser angepasst werden
[Musik]